[Music]
all right so the Democrats the media
they're desperately trying to whip you
into a frenzy about a government
shutdown now they want to create a
climate of fear and panic that is all
based on lies now let not your heart be
troubled the left they're not telling
you the truth about what is actually
going to happen if it midnight tonight
the government quote shuts down it never
really shuts down it's all an attempt to
try and use the Sun shutdown to bludgeon
once again President Trump and the
Republicans politically even though when
you look at the facts and the truth they
have nothing to do with this now seven
Senate Democrats led by Chuck Schumer
they are the ones to blame tonight they
are the ones who really in reality are
putting illegal immigrants before you
the American people daca is in place
until March it is not that urgent it is
why it is now being called tonight the
Schumer shutdown now he and liberals
they own this tonight and of course fake
news CNN the whole network well they're
taking the lead in launching a fall
shutdown narrative to try and smear the
president and Republicans now take a
look this is classic how the OMB
director Mick Mulvaney completely shuts
down and owns Jim Acosta of the fake
news network watch this
how could it be the Schumer shut down
when Republicans control the White House
the House and the Senate you know the
answer that as well as anybody I mean I
have to laugh when people say that all
we control the House the Senate the
White House why can't you get this done
you know as well as anybody that it
takes 60 votes in the Senate to pass an
appropriations bill right you know that
okay so it would you only have 51 votes
in the Senate then you have to have
Democrat support in order to keep the
government to fund the government so
that's the answer this question it seems
that the whole process was blown up by
the president's comments when
Republicans tried to add a discussion
about Obamacare to the funding process
in 2013 we are Creek used by Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer of inserting a
non fiscally non financial issue into
the spending process in order to shut
the government down how is that not
exactly what is happening today there is
no reason that you have to deal with
daca this week there's no reason you
have to deal with daca before
the end of February excuse me the middle
of February Daka doesn't expire till
March 5th this is purely an attempt by
the Senate Democrats led by mr.
Shubert's why we call - she were shut
down in order to try and get a shutdown
- they think this president gets blamed
for now fake news is CNN's Jim Acosta
he's either lying to you or he doesn't
understand that if you're in the Senate
you actually need 60 votes to break a
filibuster you paying attention Jim
that's why it's being called the Schumer
shutdown because the Democrats they're
refusing to vote on a clean continuing
resolution which they say they always
like and that includes funding for the
chip program the children's health
insurance program that they say they
wanted and wanted badly now don't
believe any of this for a second in this
particular case that Democrats actually
care about daca and the dreamers that
this is what it's about
they don't even want to dock a solution
they want to run on this in 2018 they
want to use it as a political weapon for
these midterm elections now Democrats in
the media they're also praying that this
shutdown drags on for as long as
possible because they want to stop what
the Trump economy dead in its tracks
which is not going to happen
now President Trump he has thankfully
reversed the economic decline that we
saw all the ears under Barack Obama and
the left they can't stand watching this
look at this good news for you is bad
news for them the stock market is at an
all-time high under President Trump the
Dow Jones is having its best year since
FDR was president 2.2 million jobs now
have been created unemployment in
America a 17-year low Americans filing
for unemployment get this is that a 45
year low good news Americans and African
Americans and Hispanic unemployment hit
this it's at an all-time low
under the president's policies and
consumer confidence is near an all-time
high also two million fewer people are
on food stamps today The Forgotten men
and women are being remembered finally
in other words it is a complete in one
year turnaround and the exact opposite
of what we saw during the last eight
years of Obama's failed economy they
don't want to focus on this and in
addition to being exposed as total
frauds and political hacks over the
government shutdown
well Democrats are also massive
hypocrites and we have the evidence
here's what they said back in 2013 when
they were trying to blame Republicans
for a government shutdown you might
remember this I call the legislative and
art arsonist
they're there to burn down what we
should be building up in terms of
investments in education and scientific
research and all that it is that make
our country great and competitive it's
sort of like this someone goes into your
house takes your wife and children
hostage and then says let's negotiate
over the price of your house you know we
could do the same thing on immigration
we could we believe strongly in
immigration reform we could say we're
shutting down the government we're not
going to raise the debt ceiling until
you pass immigration reform it would be
governmental ki I joined the American
people and their disgust at what
happened in terms of the shutdown of
government it's an unthinkable tactic to
use as a in the political debate the
hypocrisy stunning that's what they are
doing these people have no shame and
apparently they haven't actually figured
out that most of what they say just five
years ago is actually on videotape and
just like the media Democrats have zero
credibility on the issue now for them
this is all about scare tactics and
trying to convince you the American
people that a shutdown will lead to mass
suffering and apocalyptic like
circumstances those are all lies they've
been telling all week
now the OMB director Mick Mulvaney
explained earlier today that in 2013 and
this did happen the Obama administration
they made the shutdown as bad as
possible to score cheap political points
they did hold everything hostage and
Mulvaney he also laid out how most of
the government is going to stay open if
this quote shutdown happens in less than
about three hours what's this the Obama
administration weaponized the shutdown
in 2013 what they didn't tell you was
that they did not encourage agencies to
use
carry-forward funds carry for funds
funds that they were sitting on nor do
they encourage agencies to use transfer
Authority they could have made the
shutdown in 2013
much less impactful the military would
still go to work
they will not get paid okay the border
will still be patrolled they will not
get paid fire fire folks will still be
fighting the fires out west they will
not get paid the parks will be open
people won't get paid Fannie and Freddie
will be open the post office will be
open the TSA will be open but again all
of these people will be working for
nothing which is simply not fair we are
going to manage a shutdown differently
we are not going to weaponize it we're
not going to try and hurt people
especially people happen to work for
this federal government we're not going
to hurt people now that's the truth the
government doesn't really shut down I
hope the Democrats won't inconvenience
all these brave people that work on the
border the firemen just don't believe
the media and the Democrats that typical
scare tactics because they're not true
and very few people will tell you that
all right on to our big top story
tonight alarming shocking people will go
to jail comparisons to KGB tactics well
that is how lawmakers tonight are
describing the biggest scandal in
American history that the media is
trying to ignore they will not be able
to now Sarah Carter is reporting tonight
that more than 130 members have actually
gone to see the explosive classified
memo that shows systemic FISA abuses
against the Trump campaign and an
incoming president and according to
Sarah Carter the vast majority of those
members of Congress they happen to be
Republicans in fact only Democrats the
only ones to look at the four page memo
are the ones who are on the House
Intelligence Committee and only one
other Democrat we know of actually took
the time and went over to look at it
today and Democrats on that House
committee by the way or the ones that
voted to keep it secret from Congress
they don't want you to see it so what
are the Democrats trying to cover up in
this particular case what are they
hiding here who are they protecting here
and why do they want to keep it a secret
now tonight we are demanding that this
information be released to you the
public because the American people you
need to know about this huge and massive
abuse of power and how the Obama
administration has weaponized the
powerful tools of intelligence and how
the Clinton bought and paid for
phony Russian dossier was actually used
to not only spy on the Trump campaign
but also to get a FISA warrant based on
lies so we're asking tonight that you
call your members of Congress there's
the number it's on your screen to zero
to two to four thirty one twenty one
tell your members of Congress release
the memo that's it if you're on Twitter
hashtag release the memo we're gonna put
the number up throughout the show
tonight now I know a lot of you've been
writing and asking why is it taking so
long we have been since March we
reported first then about this abuse
that the Trump campaign had a FISA
warrant that was issued against them
that was back in March we have been
unpeeling the layers of this onion this
massive scandal and it is so imperative
we've now gotten to this point that you
need to see this information for
yourself we hope you'll call the number
on your screen the man just released the
memo tell the truth to the American
people because we have a few powerful
people in the intelligence community
well they thought they knew better than
we did than you did about who should be
the president they abuse their position
they try to influence steel rigged an
election now all that needs to happen is
this the House Intelligence Committee
they need to vote to release this
information to the public they will then
send it to the White House so I would
assume would sign off on it so in
reality with enough pressure this could
be done in a matter of days and sources
familiar with this memo they are telling
us that the contents of this memo are so
severe and so shocking that it will lead
to the firing of people at the highest
levels of the FBI and the DOJ now please
keep this in mind as we said earlier
everything that we are telling you
tonight it's only a small portion of
what will be coming out throughout this
year it's going to take time we're gonna
need your patience but the first
explosive evidence is now available
think back to Watergate Watergate was
what the third-rate break-in a group of
people trying to cover up you know a
break-in at the Watergate Hotel to get
information on an opposition candidate
this scandal is about the systemic abuse
of power
the weaponizing of the powerful tools of
intelligence against an opposition party
during an election
here and in the process shredding our
Constitution our Fourth Amendment
constitutional protections against
unreasonable search and seizure all in a
plot to impact and rig and steal an
election that's how important this is
and I don't care if you're a liberal a
conservative a Republican and Democrat
you need to care about this because we
will lose our constitutional republic if
we don't get to the bottom of this and
when all this information finally sees
the light of day it will remove any
doubt that the Special Counsel Robert
Muller his team of partisan Democratic
donors need to be disbanded and their
witch-hunt needs to be shut down
immediately and as we showed you last
night these are the key players in all
this they are high ranking Obama FBI and
DOJ officials and a lot more information
about them will be coming out in just
the next couple of weeks I think the
latest we will get this is around
January 30th but we need to see it
sooner we also know that the Trump
aiding FBI agent Peter struck and his
FBI lawyer mistress lists Lisa Paige
there at the center of everything here
and we know from the released text
messages that they called then-candidate
Trump an idiot loads them a lonesome
human being F Trump and there are still
9600 text messages that we have not seen
yet and one particular message really
gets to the heart of what we've been
trying to find out and this is between
Peter struck and Paige and now it makes
a lot more sense knowing what we know
now back in August struck wrote to Lisa
Paige well I want to believe the path
that you throw out for consideration in
Andy's office that there's no way he
gets elected but I'm afraid we can't
take that risk it's like an insurance
policy in the unlikely event that you
die before you're 40 no we of course
believe that was Andy Andy McCabe the
FBI director of course Andrew McCabe and
we also are believing tonight and we
have very strong evidence to corroborate
this that Lisa Paige was the key counsel
for McCabe you see the Nexus here you
got Lisa Paige you got Peter struck you
got Andrew McCabe what's the insurance
policy talking about an insurance policy
in case Donald Trump wins the election
and Hillary loses and at the same time
then you have the Obama administration
they're trying to obtain a FISA warrant
to spy on the Trump campaign and they
say it allegedly is about Carter page
but we know it's a pretext and sources
are telling us that the first request
for the warrant was rejected they said
no which rarely happens and that's when
the Clinton bought and paid for phony
Russian propaganda dossier was then used
now that dossier put the request over
the top and they were granted the FISA
warrant and that allowed the Obama
administration to begin the systemic
abuse of FISA spying powers to target a
candidate an opposing candidate an
opposition party in an election and this
is part of the important fusion GPS now
co-founder Glenn Simpson he testified
this was released yesterday he didn't
even bother to verify what was in the
dossier he just trusted the person he's
paying British spy Christopher Steele
even though Steele is known to have paid
Russians for information and by the way
his very skilled nature is what his
skill is deception and we're learning
from the Simpson testimony that the
Clinton campaign and the DNC knew he was
reacting in other words and reaching out
to the media outlets to try and get them
to write stories about the fabricated
Russian dossier so just like we've been
telling you Clinton bought and paid for
dossier twelve million dollars it was
going right through one lawyer through
her campaign right through another
lawyer through the DNC which he was
controlling in it what do we have
Russian lie salacious lies all in an
attempt she rigged the election against
Bernie now she's trying to rig the
election against Trump
call me instruct while they exonerate
her before an investigation you get it
there's a lot of rigging here I know
this is a lot to absorb
but there are so many questions we need
to know who knew what when and where and
let me tell you this tonight Andrew
McCabe if you're watching you need to be
fired and you need to be investigated
and by the way so does the Trump hating
FBI agent Peter struck fired and
investigated his FBI lawyer mistress
fired and
está gated Lisa page gone demoted DOJ
official Bruce or who met with Fusion
GPS before-and-after removed fired and
investigated james comey who we know
rigged in other words gave an
exoneration before investigation we
learned today is reportedly going to
teach an ethical leadership class at
William and Mary you've got to be
kidding anyway he needs to be
investigated and he may want to hire a
lawyer instead maybe an ethical one at
that rod Rosenstein you need to explain
your role in all of this and
specifically if you were involved in
extending this FISA warrant and frankly
rod Rosenstein needs to be fired and
finally tonight special counsel robert
muller his corrupt and biased
investigation needs to be shut down once
and for all
it was predicated on lies from the
beginning the country has suffered
enough and it has been unfair inaccurate
untrue and extremely and extraordinarily
and abusively biased in their tactics
and their hiring of people with
questionable ethics who in the past have
withheld exculpatory evidence were
overturned I know in a Supreme Court
people went to jail and that was
overturned in the Fifth Circuit Court of
Appeal and you only hired people that
donate it to Barack Obama Hillary and of
course the DNC what we are in covering
uncovering here is far worse than
Watergate people need to be held
accountable especially when you have
congressmen that saw the memo that say
the memo is likely to send people to
jail this is a massive abuse of power a
major violation and a shredding of
America's constitutional principles the
powerful tools of intelligence were
abused by the people at the top not the
rank and file not the FBI you know
agents out there working hard to protect
us every day not the people in the
televisions community that protect us
every day these were people at the top
instead they weaponized those tools of
intelligence to spy on an opposition
party and it is why tonight we are
asking you to help us and a man that
this memo be
to the American people that will begin
the process only beginning to show the
abuse that has taken place for the
American people call the number at the
bottom of your screen and I hope you
will demand to release the memo
hashtag released the memo